salut romain au bâton une toute petite
mine toi mon médecin m'a prescrit un
vaccin à ya un problème avec le matin
non je n'ai pas encore fait et du coup
tu a chopé une maladie ça non je sais
pas quoi faire c'est ça qui me rend
malade
bon
[Musique]
1er janvier 2018 le nombre de vaccins
obligatoires passe de 3 à 11
bon alors dit comme ça ça paraît énorme
mais en réalité la grande majorité des
enfants
ils les ont déjà ces vaccins donc ça n'a
juste devenir obligatoire pour les
autres des marques et je comprends qu'on
puisse se poser des questions sur les
vaccins surtout qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui font circuler un paquet
contre-vérités sur le sujet du coup je
vous propose un petit mito buster sur
les neuf bullshit qu'on entend sur les
vaccins se vacciner c'est un choix
personnel
ça doit pas être obligatoire alors en
fait c'est pas si simple que ça quand on
se fait vacciner
c'est pour éviter d'attraper une maladie
et on sait que déjà ça s'est compliqué
pour pas mal de gens parce que ça
revient à prendre des médicaments pour
une maladie qu'on a pas pour pas la voir
justement ça s'appelle de la prévention
on a du mal avec la prévention bien
manger pas fumer pas trop boire pas
rouler trop vite on a du mal mais se
faire vacciner contre une maladie fait
aussi éviter de la transmettre
et dans le cas de certaines maladies ça
veut dire éviter une épidémie et tous
les problèmes qui vont avec
genre de handicap ou la mort et pour
être sûr d'éviter une épidémie il faut
que suffisamment de personnes soient
vaccinés sinon ça marche pas et
aujourd'hui les seules maladies pour
lesquelles on arrive à 95 % de personnes
vaccinées
c'est celles pour lesquelles la
vaccination est déjà obligatoire ça
s'appelle la santé publique est c'est
fait pour protéger tout le monde et
notamment ceux qui peuvent pas se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils ont une
contre-indication médicale
c'est un acte citoyen en fait la société
la communauté elle te protège avec la
sécu et plein de trucs tu te protège et
et tu protèges la communauté donc c'est
pas juste une histoire personnelle
oui mais il ya d'autres moyens de se
protéger que la vaccination genre quoi
là on est en train de parler d'une
méthode qui a permis de mettre fin aux
pires épidémies de l'histoire et d'en
éviter d'autres et au delà des épidémies
on parle d'une méthode qui garantit de
ne pas choper des maladies atroce et
mortelle genre le tétanos pour citer que
celles là et en face propose quoi alors
marien en fait en tout cas rien qu'à
prouver que ça marchait remettre en
question le seul truc tu as
scientifiquement prouvé son efficacité
pour le remplacer par des méthodes comme
ça au feeling ce serait prendre un
risque énorme hommes voire des maladies
ou des épidémies réapparaître alors il y
en a qui disent qu'on peut laisser faire
notre système immunitaire de façon
naturelle
mais si ça marchait il y aurait pas eu
toutes ces maladies toutes ces épidémies
ces handicaps lourds etc ces mêmes
justement pour ça que
ils ont été créés parce que ça suffit
pas on ce vaccin obligatoire ça veut
dire 11 piqûre pour les enfants plus les
rappels c'est trop en fait non pas ce
qu'ont fait plusieurs vaccins avec une
même pictures techniquement entre les
vaccins et les rappels
ça fait des piqûres répartis sur deux
ans est aujourd'hui plus de 70 % des
enfants les ont déjà sévi pictures avec
les onze vaccin obligatoire on augmente
juste le nombre d'enfants vaccinés et on
les protège eux et tous les autres et
tout le monde en fait parce qu'on
empêche des maladies de circuler ces
maladies elles ont disparu
de toute façon et non la maladière
centre a disparu suivant les cas soit
presque plus personne les attrape
soit on a endigué les grandes épidémies
et vous savez pourquoi
parce que les gens sont vaccinés mais
pas assez parce qu'il ya encore des
morts ou des séquelles qui sont
évitables
c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer
l'effort et nous on a de la chance qu'on
a accès à ces vaccins là mais c'est loin
d'être le cas partout non du coup il ya
des endroits dans le monde où des
maladies comme la polio par exemple ça
existe encore et après un voyage on peut
ramener la maladie et la transmettre et
des voyages de plus en plus attention
rien qu'en france des cas de rougeole
des hépatites des infections à
méningocoques
là il y en a encore oui mais uniquement
sur la gravité des maladies pour nous
forcer à nous vacciner alors on va faire
simple la polio s attaquent à notre
système nerveux central et un peu
provoquer des paralysies qui peuvent
même aller jusqu'à paralyser les muscles
qui nous font respirer la rubéole elle
peut entraîner des malformations
congénitales ou la mort du foetus
chez les femmes enceintes l'hépatite b
elle peut dégénérer en cirrhose ou en
cancer du foie
la rougeole elle peut atteindre le
cerveau et les organes qui a autour et
causé des encéphalites il ya une jeune
fille non vaccinés de 16 ans qui en est
morte en juin dernier à marseille et je
vous parle pas du pneumocoque du
méningocoque de l'haemophilus influenzae
qui peuvent causer des mets
gîtes et je vous parle pas non plus des
autres maladies mais potentiellement
elles sont toutes mortelle et
contagieuse
ok mais les vaccins c'est dangereux à
nous y voilà pour simplifier on va dire
qu'un vaccin fait un médicament comprend
pas pour soigner une maladie mais pour
éviter de l'attraper et de la refiler à
tout le monde
tous les médicaments ont des effets
secondaires potentiels peuvent être
fréquents ou art bénin ou graves
globalement les bénin ça peut arriver
mais on parle de trucs genre l'endroit
où on a fait la piqûre qui grattent qui
fait un peu mal un peu de fièvre etc
mais les effets indésirables graves ils
sont super rare c'est même la condition
à laquelle on autorise la vente d'un
médicament ou d'un vaccin qui fasse plus
de bien que de mal
ça s'appelle la balance bénéfices
risques et c'est réévaluée régulièrement
si vous devez retenir une seule chose
retenait sa le risque de choper une
maladie grave si on n'est pas vaccinée
il est beaucoup plus élevé que le risque
d'avoir un effet indésirable grave lié à
max ouais enfin il ya quand même des
vaccins qui donne la sclérose en plaques
ou qui rendent autistes alors pour
l'autisme soyons très clairs il y à une
étude de 1998 qui disait qu'il y avait
un lien entre le vaccin rer et l'autisme
depuis toutes les études menées montrent
que c'est faux et la fameuse étude de
1998 ça a été prouvé que non seulement
elle était bidon mais en plus elles
étaient malhonnêtes
d'ailleurs la majorité des gens qui
l'avaient mené depuis où se sont
rétractés alors pour la sclérose en
plaques
c'est un peu différent dans les années
90 quand on a commencé à beaucoup
vacciner contre l'hépatite b
des gens qui ont développé une sclérose
en plaques ont accusé les vaccins il ya
plein d'études qui ont été menées sur ce
sujet ce qu'il en est ressorti c'est que
la maladie s'est déclarée chez des
adolescents ou des jeunes adultes c'est
à dire à l'âge où elle se déclare
habituellement et que les gens vaccinés
nous pas plus de risque de développer
une sclérose en plaques que les non
vaccinés
par contre les non vaccinés il
plus de risque de choper une hépatite b
il ya de l'aluminium dans les vaccins ça
fait super dangereux
bah non c'est toujours le même problème
en fait il ya des gens qui disent oh là
là l'aluminium monde ira bien que ça
provoque des maladies musculaires et
derrière rien enfin si derrière on fait
des études des recherches pour vérifier
bon déjà des adjuvants à base
d'aluminium
il y en a dans quasiment tous les
vaccins ça booste le système immunitaire
et ça rend le vaccin plus efficace et
alors donc les études elles disent quoi
d'allemands que oui il ya un peu
d'aluminium qui restent dans la zone où
on a fait l'injection mais que non rien
ne permet de dire que ça provoque des
maladies
en fait les faibles d'aluminum ils sont
utilisés depuis plus de 90 ans et on
vaccine des dizaines de millions de
personnes dans le monde entier
chaque année la fameuse balance bénéfice
risque elle est très nettement en faveur
du nombre de vies sauvées
surtout que le risque qu'il a même pas
été prouvée de toute façon tout ça c'est
un complot c'est juste pour engraisser
les labos dans la mesure où plus de 70%
des enfants ont déjà les mots ce vaccin
et que les autres noms certains mais pas
tous pour des entreprises comme des
labos pharmaceutiques se représente pas
un chiffre d'affaires significatif c'est
pas du tout les acteurs et ça va pas non
plus coûter un bras à l'état pour les
mêmes raisons et parce qu'en plus ça va
permettre d'éviter des dépenses pour des
maladies qu'on n'aura pas à soigner
grâce au vaccin
bon on fait le point se poser des
questions c'est normal douter
systématiquement des réponses même si
99% de la communauté scientifique
mondiale vous dis la même chose voir des
complots partout
- bon soyons factuel juste avec les
vaccins contre la diphtérie le tétanos
la rougeole est la coqueluche on évite
deux à trois millions de morts par an
dans le monde selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé d'après l'unicef
les vaccins sont en tout environ 9
millions de vies dans le monde chaque
année et ça pourrait en sauver 16
millions de plus si la vaccination était
attendu c'est une méthode qui a fait ses
preuves c'est une méthode qui a permis à
millions de personnes ne pas être malade
c'est une méthode qui a permis
d'endiguer des épidémies et toutes les
études scientifiques menées montrent que
vous prenez beaucoup moins de risque en
vous vaccinant qu'en refusant de le
faire beaucoup moins de risques pour
vous et beaucoup moins de risques pour
les autres
bon maintenant je vais vous expliquer
comment ça fonctionne vraiment un vaccin
enfin les déjà pas mal non david et ola
dans bruce brute c'est toi c'est moi
c'est pas du jeu que je te propose si
t'es ok c'est que moi je fais une vidéo
sur le fonctionnement des vaccins ok
donc pour en savoir plus je vous renvoie
vers la vidéo de bruce sur y penser je
vous mets le lien partout du coup dtc
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là protégez-vous et
protéger les autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porté venu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]